in his first TV interview since he
abruptly resigned a former Immigration
and Customs and 4th enforcement
spokesman opens up about why he quit
back in March
James swab alleges that he was asked to
spread alive for the Trump
administration our cameras were rolling
as homeland security agents from the
inspector general's office unexpectedly
showed up at his door yesterday they
appeared during an interview with Jamie
yuccas she joins us from outside the ice
office in San Francisco Jamie that was a
surprise good morning it was a surprise
good morning Gail James Schwab says
before he resigned he worked for the
federal government for 17 years most
recently here at the Immigration and
Customs Bay Area headquarters he admits
that he was asked to spin information
for both the Obama and Trump White
House's but he says he felt compelled to
resign after the current administration
told him to lie about an incident that
pitted the government against Oakland's
mayor tensions in the San Francisco Bay
Area were running high in February over
a series of raids carried out by federal
agents with Immigration and Customs
Enforcement or ice with the guidance of
his superiors in Washington DC it fell
to James Schwab to communicate with
journalists about those raids the day
before the operation took place the
Oakland Mayor surprised us and announced
our operation here's my message to Mayor
chef how dare you how dare you distort
the reality she was putting your
officers why was potentially in danger
correct we end up arresting 232 which is
16% higher than our highest estimates so
internally that was considered a success
but what they publicly said was that she
let people go and that wasn't true true
right
Schwab helped craft a statement to the
media saying some of them were able to
elude us thanks to the mayor's
irresponsible decision he was
comfortable with that statement he says
because it included the words some of
this is a spin statement this is what
every public affairs officer does a week
later Attorney General Jeff Sessions
language was noticeably different iced
failed to make 800 or
that would have been made if the mayor
had not made her statement
those are 800 wanted criminals that are
not large in that community that made
you uncomfortable
completely false yes that made me
extremely uncomfortable when reporters
asked him to clarify the discrepancy
Schwab says he was instructed by his
superiors in Washington to simply refer
to the original statement he drafted
without disputing sessions version of
events after they failed to correct it
it's a flat-out lie they know it's a lie
it was just shocking to me that no one
wanted to fix that trouble by what he
saw as public deception Schwab turned in
his resignation I could not fathom
staying at an organization that was okay
with lying to the American public I hate
that in 17 years in the military at the
Department of Defense as a civilian at
NASA and now at Homeland Security I have
never been asked to lie I have never
been asked to perpetuate a lie which is
the same as lying well we talked to
Schwab on Wednesday some three months
after he quit we were interrupted by a
surprise
he had unexpected visitors at the front
door of his home the men identified
themselves as agents from the Department
of Homeland Security Inspector General's
Office is about the incident he were in
his home so I'm talking to him this is
confidential okay
they just said that they wanted to talk
to me about the leak with the Oakland
Mayor were you surprised to see them
completely shocked unexpected did you
ever contact the Oakland mayor's office
no I've never met her before I never
contacted you didn't believe I'd never
emailed never I would never tell her I
would never tell anyone they were very
serious
he was very starting with me and it was
concerning do you think that was an
intimidation technique absolutely
absolutely why three months later
are we doing this this is intimidation
and this is why people won't come out
and speak against the government do you
believe that other agencies are
struggling with this their spokespeople
are struggling with what you've gone
through I I know that they are because
they've reached out to me Schwab says
he's speaking out now because he's
talked to others in the federal
government with similar concerns that's
one of the most important reasons that
I'm doing this is this so that people
hear that someone else stood up that
someone else said no and was concerned
with it to actually prepare and stand
out in front of the public and
perpetuate something that you know is
absolutely false it's not okay and no
special agent from Department of
Homeland Security is going to stop me
from saying that we reached out to ice
they said they disagree with Schwab's
characterization that he was asked to
lie they also pointed out that the
mayor's actions did allow at least some
targets to evade arrest Homeland
Security did not get back to us about
any investigations into who leaked
details about the raid and although
Schwab is a registered Democrat he says
it has nothing to do with his decision
to resign and to speak out glad what an
incredible moment there Jamie what was
going through your mind as these men
showed up at the door well when we first
heard the knock it was kind of out of
place everybody seemed to think you know
what's going on here they weren't
expecting anybody to come to the house
he had some family members there as well
who had come to watch the interview so
it was a total surprise to everyone once
we heard that it was homeland security
that's how they identified themselves we
quickly went down
there's and as you saw tried to ask them
some questions they wanted nothing to do
with us I can tell you that
James Schwab was initially seemed a
little bit nervous about them being
there and then seemed very angry
afterward he had to calm some of his
family members down and reassure them
that things were going to be okay an
incredible moment there Thank You Jamie
the fact that he's speaking out I wonder
if others will speak out too since he
says that he knows that other people
feel the way he did I think it's very
brave what he's doing yeah someone
apparently looks like he has served his
country many years right or will they be
intimidated though when you know that
they could just show up at your door at
any moment in time